5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, DISSES
"ONE MORE THING"."
"THE FIVE"."
PARTISAN POLITICS ARE CRIPPLING
AMERICA’S RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS, CHUCK SCHUMER AND
SENATE DEMOCRATS BLOCKING A
CRITICAL STIMULUS BILL FOR A
SECOND TIME.
IT WOULD PROVIDE OVER
$1 TRILLION TO MILLIONS OF
WORKERS AND BUSINESSES DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE OUTBREAK.
IT COMES AS AMERICA’S SURGEON
GENERAL WARNS THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE A BAD WEEK FOR THE
COUNTRY.
INFECTIONS ARE SOARING IN
AMERICA, WITH OVER 40,000 CASES
AND 500 500 DEAD.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL CALLING OUT
DEMOCRATS FOR PRIORITIZING THEIR
WISH LIST INSTEAD OF BACKING A
CLEAN STIMULUS BILL.
HERE IS JUST SOME OF THE
BACK-AND-FORTH.
>> IT’S TIME FOR DEMOCRATS TO
STOP PLAYING POLITICS AND STEP
UPUP TO THE PLATE.
THE ENTIRE ECONOMY CONTINUES TO
CRUMBLE.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE ITEMS ON
THE DEMOCRATIC WISH LIST OVER
WHICH THEY CHOOSE TO BLOCK THIS
LEGISLATION.
TAX CREDITS FOR SOLAR ENERGY AND
WIND ENERGY, PROVISIONS TO FORCE
EMPLOYERS TO GIVE SPECIAL
TREATMENT TO BIG LABOR, AND
LISTEN TO THIS, NEW EMISSION
STANDARDS FOR THE AIRLINES.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> MAY BE THE MAJORITY LEADER
THINKS IT’S UNFAIR TO ASK FOR
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS, THAT IS
A WISH LIST FOR WORKERS.
NOBODY ELSE.
>> OVER IN THE HOUSE,
NANCY PELOSI INTRODUCING HER OWN
STIMULUS PLAN.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON IMMEDIATE
RELIEF, PELOSI IS ATTACKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER OBAMACARE.
>> I AM CALLING ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO ABANDON HIS
LAWSUIT SEEKING TO STRIKE OUT
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
HE SHOULD URGE THE 14 STATES WHO
HAVE REFUSED TO EXPAND MEDICAID
TO DO SO.
TODAY, HOUSE DEMOCRAT TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WORKERS AND
FAMILIES ACT, A BILL THAT TAKES
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE HEALTH
AND WELL-BEING OF AMERICA’S
WORKERS.
>> MR. I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS IT
ISN’T GOING TO BE PERFECT, I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MAY BE TWICE
AS MUCH OR FAMILIES AND 24
WORKERS.
I DON’T SEE ANYTHING WRONG WITH
HAVING STRINGS ATTACHED, FOR
ATTACHING STRINGS TO THINGS LIKE
MAKING SURE THERE ARE MORE WOMEN
ON BOARDS OR MORE GREEN NEW
DEAL, THAT’S FINE, THAT’S NOT
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
>> TO YOUR POINT, DOES IT HAVE
TO BE PERFECT?
WE ARE NOT IN A TIME OF LUXURY
WHERE YOU CAN HONE THIS PACKAGE
TO AN IDEAL THING, WHEN A
FIREFIGHTER IS FACING A BLAZED
HE STOP AND GO HEY, EXCUSE ME,
IS THAT MINERAL OR TAPWATER?
YOU GET THE HOSE AND YOU POINTED
AT THE FIRE.
THIS RELIEF PACKAGE IS THE HOSE
AND WATER THAT WE NEED.
I CONSIDER MYSELF A LAYPERSON, I
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IS WRONG WITH
THIS BILL.
IDEOLOGICAL LANGUAGE OBSCURES
THE TRUTH.
THE LAY PEOPLE CANNOT SEE WHAT
IS GOING ON.
IT’S LIKE WE NEED A VISUAL MODEL
TO SHOW US WHAT THESE VOTES OF
CONTENTION ARE, WHAT ARE THE
ABSURDITIES AND WHAT AREN’T THE
ABSURDITIES.
A CHART, A GRAPH, A DOLL.
THIS IS WHERE THEY DISAGREE,
THIS IS WHERE THEY DON’T.
INSTEAD, WE SEE HOW POLITICS
UNDERMINES EVERYTHING.
ODDLY, POLITICS IS THE INVISIBLE
VIRUS THAT IS GOING TO BEAT US.
IT IS GOING TO BE A CORONAVIRUS,
IF THIS KEEPS US FROM GETTING
THE STIMULUS THEN WE ARE ALL
SCREWED.
YOU KNOW WHAT, WE ARE AS
AMERICANS ASKED TO SACRIFICE.
WE ARE TOLD TO STAY IN OUR HOMES
AND NOT GO TO WORK.
THEY SHOULD DO THEIR JOBS.
THEY SHOULDN’T STOP PLAYING
THEIR STUPID GAME AND MATCH OUR
SACRIFICE OR ELSE THEY FORGOT US
AS CITIZENS.
>> IT IS AMAZING HOW THE WHOLE
COUNTRY CAN COME TOGETHER EXCEPT
POLITICIANS IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> IN FAIRNESS TO THE
POLITICIANS, KEEP IN MIND, THIS
WOULD BE THE THIRD.
THEY ALREADY PASSED ONE BILL TO
PUT MORE MONEY INTO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HEALTH CARE RESPONSE,
ALL THE FEDERAL AGENCIES THAT
DEAL WITH HEALTH CARE.
THEN SECONDLY, PASSED SOME MONEY
TO HELP WITH UNEMPLOYMENT, TO
HELP WITH PAID LEAVE, AND EVEN
IN SOME CASES TO HELP PEOPLE
WITH THEIR HEALTH CARE COSTS.
SO THIS IS A STEP THAT IS MEANT
IN TERMS OF A LARGER ECONOMY, IN
THAT REGARD THE KEY TO MY MIND
IS THAT THEY SHOULD BE VERY
CAREFUL HERE.
WHAT WE WANT IS TO PUT MORE
MONEY IN PEOPLE’S POCKETS
BECAUSE CONSUMER SPENDING IS THE
KEY TO OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
DOWN THE ROAD.
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
PAY THEIR BILLS.
>> IF THEY ARE UNEMPLOYED OR
WHATEVER, BUT THEY DON’T STOP
PAYING THEIR BILLS.
INSTEAD, WITH THE DEMOCRATS SEE,
THEY SEE A $425 BILLION
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IS BEING
GIVEN TO THE FEDERAL RESERVE
THAT THE INCUMBENT
ADMINISTRATION CAN DECIDE WHO
GETS UP MONEY, WHO DOESN’T GET
THAT MONEY.
CONGRESS WOULD HAVE VERY LITTLE
OR NO OVERSIGHT, AND THEY ARE
WORRIED IT BECOMES WHAT THEY ARE
CALLING A FLUSH FUND.
FOR BIG
BUSINESS, THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT UNLIKE 2,008, WHEN A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAID AFTERWARDS ON MY
GOSH THIS WAS TOO BIG TO FAIL,
WE PILLED OUT WALL STREET AGAIN
AGAIN.
JOE MANCHIN THE SENATOR FROM
WEST VIRGINIA WAS ON THE FLOOR
ARGUING WITH MITCH McCONNELL,
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER, HE
SAID WE DON’T HAVE MASS
CONGRESSIONAL DELETEMASKS,VENTIL
BE HERE RATHER THAN ON
WALL STREET.
>> WE DON’T WANT A BAILOUT
AGAIN, IT IS NOT THE FAULT OF
THESE INDUSTRIES THAT THEY
DIDN’T CAUSE THIS RECESSION.
YOU ARE JUST KIND OF GIVING THEM
LIQUIDITY SO THEY CAN KEEP
EMPLOYEES INSTEAD OF FIRING THEM
OR GIVE THEM ACCESS TO CAPITAL
IN TERMS OF LOANS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO STAY AFLOAT.
>> THIS IS NOT JUST WALL STREET,
THIS IS FAR FROM IT.
THESE ARE THE COMPANY IS NOT ALL
AMERICANS WORK FOR.
THIS IS A LARGE SWATH OF THE
U.S. ECONOMY THAT HAS BASICALLY
BEEN PUT OUT OF BUSINESS
OVERNIGHT.
THEY ARE SUFFERING, NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN.
JUST LIKE INDIVIDUALS, JUST LIKE
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN LAID
OFF, THE MILLIONS WHO HAVE BEEN
LAID OFF AND TO CORRECT ONE, THE
$425 BILLION GOES TO THE
TREASURY AND AS A BACKSTOP
FOR LENDING AT THE
FEDERAL RESERVE, WHICH WOULD
TOTAL ABOUT $4 TRILLION.
THAT IS HOW YOU CAN LEVERAGE
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY, THAT IS
WHY THIS IS CRITICAL.
WHILE CONGRESS IS FLAILING AND
FAILING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND
DITHERING AND BICKERING, IT IS
THE NERDS OVER AT THE FED THAT
HAVE STEPPED UP TODAY WITH
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO RESCUE THIS
ECONOMY.
WE ARE GOING ALL IN TO LENDING
FACILITIES TO MAKE SURE
CORPORATIONS ARE NOT FAILING.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY
DO?
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
GREAT DEPRESSION FOR THE NEXT
DECADE, LEAVE IT TO THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
REALLY QUICKLY, THE FED IS ALSO
PLANNING TO ROLL OUT A
MAIN STREET BUSINESS LENDING
PROGRAM THAT WILL SUPPORT
LENDING TO SMALL AND MIDSIZE
BUSINESSES BUT THEY NEED HELP
FROM CONGRESS TO BACKSTOP THAT.
SO WHERE ARE WE?
WE ARE STARING INTO THE ABYSS
BECAUSE OF THOSE LOSERS IN
CONGRESS.
>> DANA, IT LOOKS LIKE THEY HAD
SOMEWHAT OF A DEAL AT SOME POINT
OVER THE WEEKEND AND
NANCY PELOSI FLIES IN FROM
CALIFORNIA AND THROWS THE WHOLE
THING HAYWIRE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SHE WAS
CALCULATING THERE?
>> WELL, I THINK IT IS A PRETTY
STARK SITUATION ONE MITCH
McCONNELL WOULD RATHER BE
WORKING WITH HARRY REID THEN
CHUCK SCHUMER AT THIS
MOMENT, AS YOU KNOW OR MIGHT
REMEMBER THEY DID NOT GET ALONG
SO WELL.
AT LEAST HARRY REID WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN SWITCHED AROUND BY THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
LAST WEEKEND, MITCH McCONNELL
MADE ALL SORTS OF RIDICULOUS
ACCUSATIONS OF HIM NOT WORKING
THROUGH THE WEEKEND.
THERE WASN’T A BILL FOR THEM TO
WORK ON OVER THE WEEKEND,
INSTEAD WHAT YOU HAVE IS THEM
HOLDING THINGS UP, MAKING THE
STOCK MARKET GO DN EVEN
FURTHER, AND THE PRESIDENT SAID
THIS FROM THE BEGINNING, THIS IS
NOT THE FAULT OF THE WORKERS.
THEY DID NOTHING WRONG.
THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE THAT
WEREN’T PAYING THEIR MORTGAGES,
OR WITH THE WALL STREET BANK
SITUATION.
THIS IS NOTHING LIKE THAT.
THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO STEP UP BIG
AND FAST, IT IS NOT GOING TO BE
PERFECT.
REMEMBER, WITH WALL STREET,
THOSE BANKS PAID BACK THE MONEY
PRETTY QUICKLY BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY GOT BACK UP AND RUNNING.
WE NEED THE ECONOMY TO BE BACK
UP AND RUNNING QUICKLY, THEY
NEED TO DO IT BIG.
I THINK IT WILL PROBABLY GET IT
DONE BY MIDNIGHT TONIGHT.
>> THAT WOULD BE FANTASTIC, JUST
IN TIME FOR THE MARKET TO OPEN.
>> THERE MIGHT BE A PROCEDURAL
REASON THE DEMOCRATS MIGHT HAVE
SCREWED THIS UP SO MUCH THAT
THEY CAN’T VOTE UNTIL WEDNESDAY,
BUT I KNOW THAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO IT FAST.